lorsque j'arrive ici devant vous pour ce
tedx jeu
si je ressens
le meilleur de moi même j'ai
l'impression de revivre les instants où
j'étais sportif de haut niveau et de
vivre les instants en tant
qu'entrepreneur aujourd'hui je suis
guillaume adam ans à la tête de l'équipe
de france d'athlétisme et cofondateur du
rhône motion coach je souhaite vous
montrer à quel point le sport de haut
niveau et l'entrepreneuriat sont des
mondes proches et en quoi pour moi un
entrepreneur est un sportif de haut
niveau
la vie est faite de rencontres
certaines vous donner une nouvelle
impulsion certaine vous vont vous
inspirer et penser à ces à ces
rencontres qui ont changé votre vie pour
certains c'est peut-être ce professeur
de droit qui vous a donné envie de faire
du droit
c'est peut-être pour certains un artiste
a peut-être en motion design pour moi la
rencontre qui va marquer c'est celle de
mon premier entraîneur alex pour moi au
début l'athlétisme c'était avant tout un
jeu et je voulais surtout m'amuser avec
mes copains et petit à petit alex a su
me transmettre sa passion
me transmettre les valeurs de la course
à pied c'est à dire la persévérance le
travail et j'ai eu un jour un rêve quand
j'étais enfant c'était celui de porter
le maillot de l'équipe de france
d'athlétisme
quelques années après suite à quelques
échecs mais aussi surtout beaucoup de
moments de joie
j'ai réussi à vivre ce rêve et a porté
le maillot de l'équipe de france à deux
reprises aujourd'hui art avant c'est à
mon tour de conseillers et à mon tour
d'inspirer des milliers de coureurs
il ya trois ans je suis parti du côté de
boston et je m'entraînais dans le club
du bassin d'anticosti shon qui organise
le marathon de boston depuis 1897
je suis bénévole sur le marathon de 2017
et quelques jours après donc j'ai pu
aussi encourager mes amis et surtout la
foule de milliers de coureurs est ce que
j'ai pu me rendre compte
c'est à quel point le marathon c'est une
expérience extraordinaire c'est une
aventure il ya quel point le marathon
pouvait être structurant dans une vie
quelques jours après je
je suis invité par le club pour pour une
soirée avec des bénévoles et je
rencontre thorton qui a couru le
marathon et torsten lui est chercheur et
mighty quelques semaines plus tard il
lui propose de rejoindre son équipe pour
travailler sur la prédiction de
performance en course à pied
je peux alors à la fois exercer mon
métier d'ingénieur est également vivre
de ma passion pour la course à pied je
me rencontrent à travers cette petite
rencontre que j'ai une étincelle
je me dis c'est possible de pouvoir à la
fois faire son métier est également
vivre de sa passion
justement le dénominateur commun de ces
deux rencontres c'est pour moi de me
rends compte que le que ces rencontres
là m'ont permis de me rendre compte que
le rêve est possible au même moment j'ai
envie de créer un service pour permettre
aux coureurs de s'épanouir
et pour y arriver j'ai besoin d'une
équipe je suis sûr que vous avez
remarqué la puissance d'un collectif et
à comment ensemble on peut soulever des
montagnes
j'aime d'ailleurs bien ce proverbe
africain qui est seul on va plus vite
ensemble on va plus loin
alors quand on est sportif de haut
niveau moi je me suis entouré avant tout
d'un coach c'est la personne qui vous
allez conversion que vous allez vivre au
quotidien
c'est la personne qui va
vous apportez tout une autre technique
j'avais également un nutritionniste un
préparateur mental pour certains peut
également rajouter un attaché de presse
pour gérer différents intérêts
médiatiques
on peut aussi ajouter un agent pour les
intérêts économiques et ça dans un seul
but celui de permettre à la tête de
performant le jour j et le coureur doit
se focaliser sur un seul point
s'entraîner et donner le meilleur de
lui-même le jour j dans
l'entrepreneuriat on peut faire les
mêmes parallèle lorsque j'ai eu mon idée
de créer road motion je me suis entouré
de réintégrer un incubateur ici sous
cerveau technolac
j'ai également intégré un incubateur
annecy spécialisé dans l'industrie du
sport est en fête
l'ordonnancé un incubateur ou dans ces
accélérateurs on fait des rencontres
il ya des personnes qui ont mené à nous
aider pour que l'idée devienne un
concept et que le concept devient
ensuite une entreprise lorsqu'on crée
une entreprise on a également besoin de
s'entourer de personnes qui vont vous
aider pour pour déposer les statuts donc
vous allez avoir un avocat
vous allez avoir un expert comptable et
dans le cas pour moi du de la création
d'une application
j'ai également rencontré des
développeurs qui m'ont permis de pouvoir
rendre réel
mon concept de d'une application de
coaching est le plus important dans le
choix de ses prestataires
c'est avant tout de prendre des
personnes qui partagent les mêmes
valeurs que vous des personnes qui sont
convaincus de votre rêve et qui vont
vous aider sur le chemin pour y arriver
j'ai la chance d'entreprendre avec mon
frère jumeau romain on a des parcours
qu'on était complémentaires lui sur la
partie économique moi c'est la partie
ingénierie et ce qui fait notre force
aujourd'hui c'est d'avoir une confiance
aveugle l'un envers l'autre et comme ça
ça me permet d'aller plus vite afin
d'aller plus loin justement ensemble et
aujourd'hui on vient de recruter nos
premiers salariés et aussi partage notre
vision est en vie dedans mener notre
entreprise loin et avec l'ambition de
permettre à chacun de s'épanouir par la
course
si l'on s'entraîne si dure si l'on
travaille si dur c'est avant tout pour
atteindre son objectif pour atteindre
son rêve c'est en quelque sorte pour
bousculer son destin en athlétisme
la finalité c'est avant tout de gagner
des courses de battre ses records
lorsque je me suis rendu compte lorsque
j'étais dans différents groupes
d'entraînement qui a des personnes qui
vont venir fin qui qui confondait en
fait le chemin pour y arriver l'objectif
et des personnes c'est ce qu'on appelle
nous dans le jargon c'est des champions
du moment l'entraînement des personnes
qui vont tout donner à l'entraînement
qui vont parfois se perdre en chemin est
en fait le but
si on s'entraîne dur à l'entraînement
c'est avant tout pour gagner le jour j
et si on donne tout à l'entraînement on
va
déjà d'une part peut-être se mettre trop
la pression le jour j et moi par exemple
je n'étais pas le meilleur à
l'entraînement mais ce qui fait ma force
c'était ma capacité à me libérer le jour
j c'est ma capacité à me transcender
donc ça c'est des états mentaux de que
le sportif va rechercher avant tout
puisque quand on quand on rentre dans ce
qu'on appelle la zone c des instants de
grâce cet instant où tout vous réussit
j'ai la chance de vivre à quelques
reprises chaque année et c'est quelque
chose de très de très forts de très
puissants on a l'impression d'être
d'être invincible mais absent que tout
nous réussit et par exemple pour moi là
dedans dernier marathon que j'ai fait
que j'ai couru en 2h26 pour vous 2h26
vous avez vous dire c'est super long je
peux penser à plein de choses et en fait
non quand on est contenue dans la zone
quand on est focalisé sur son geste
focalisé sur soi ça pas si perlite et
dans ma tête le marathon finalement il
s'est passé un c'est comme s'il ya eu
que quelques minutes
donc on se rend compte quand on est dans
la zone sait aussi qu'il ya un espace
temps qui est récit et que on a
l'impression que que tout nous réussit
alors dans le dans l'entrepreneuriat il
ya également quelques moments clés même
si la finalité c'est pas de gagner des
courses mais il peut y avoir des
d'autres moments clés par exemple
lorsqu'on sort un nouveau produit
lorsqu'on sort à un nouveau service
lorsqu'on fait une présentation devant
des investisseurs ou donc il ya ce
parallèle est aujourd'hui le fait
d'avoir vécu cette première expérience
de sportif de haut niveau c'est une
force aujourd'hui pour moi dans
l'entreprenariat et je suis sûr qu'on
peut également de vivre dans d'autres
domaines
peut-être artistique ou même dans la vie
de tous les jours ce sont dix ce sont
des paroles que l'on peut trouver
alors il m'a fallu dix ans pour vivre
mon rêve en athlétisme
j'ai créé mon entreprise il ya
maintenant deux ans et j'espère que je
vais vivre des moments aussi forts dans
l'entrepreneuriat et le fait d'avoir
vécu avant est une force
le point commun de ces deux expériences
c'est avant tout le dépassement de soi
et une envie de donner le meilleur sur
rennes pour terminer j'aimerais que vous
prenez quelques instants
pour repenser à toutes ces rencontres
qui vous ont marqué pendant votre vie à
toutes ces rencontres vous avez une
petite étincelle
je vous invite également vous entourer
de personnes qui vont vous aider pour
atteindre votre rêve surtout ce chemin
là et surtout mon dernier conseil c'est
de profiter un maximum
lorsque vous serez en train de vivre vos
rêves et de le vivre pleinement
merci
[Applaudissements]